cyberpunk 2077 fans are asking for cloud
saves on stadia and other developers are
reacting to the news of the service
coming to an end
if you missed it Google announced its
Cloud streaming service stadia will
officially be shut down on January 18
2023 all stadia Hardware purchases made
through the Google Store will be
refunded including games and add-on
content purchased from that specific
storefront cyberpunk 2077 is one of
those games that has been available to
Stevia Gamers since launch but with the
services looming Doom that means lots of
fans may have to start their journey in
nice city all over again over on the
stadia subreddit one user asked CD
projekt Red to add Cloud saves to the
stadia version of cyberpunk and added
quote I care more about my saved game
than a game refund other members of the
community came to the rescue suggesting
the use of Google takeout a service that
allows users to grab data off of
Google's services this would allow
players to download the save files and
import them into steam or Gog there are
a number of replies in the thread
confirming that this method works but
there are also a good handful of users
that are having trouble with the
workaround as stadia was failing to show
up in their takeout menu at the time of
this recording there is no word from
cdpr about the possibility of cloud
saves for stadia's version of cyberpunk
but January is still a couple months
away so anything can happen for now if
you happen to be dealing with this issue
keep giving Google takeout a try with
your fingers crossed meanwhile other
developers are taking steps to help make
sure stadia Gamers have a smooth
transition away from the platform for
example IO interactive tweeted quote to
all our Hitman fans on Google stadia we
hear you we are looking into ways for
you to continue your Hitman experience
on other platforms Ubisoft also reacted
to the news of stadia's demise and are
offering PC versions of stadia games to
purchasers in a statement Ubisoft said
quote while stadia will shut down on
January 18 2023 we are happy to share
that we are currently working to bring
the games you own on stadia to PC
through Ubisoft connect we'll have more
to share regarding specific details as
well as the impact for Ubisoft plus
subscribers at a later date and with
stadia's doom on the horizon you might
be wondering what cloud service you
should try out next the obvious choice
is Xbox but if you're an Amazon Prime
member you have access to a couple of
games each month that you can play for
no additional fee on Amazon's Cloud
platform Luna October's editions have
been recently announced and they're
worth a peek Metro Exodus might be the
most enticing game of the bunch offering
a horrific post-apocalyptic world to
explore you'll play as a Survivor that's
seeking refuge in the tunnels below
Moscow before heading out to find
greener pastures and start anew if
you're looking for something a bit
lighter you can enjoy skateboard this
month this quirky Indie has you zipping
around as a bird on a skateboard racking
up points by stringing together Combos
and completing a variety of challenges
on each stage other games in the October
Prime gaming channel lineup include the
iconic platformer earthworm gym 2
nightmare and using Blair Witch and
monster truck Championship hit the
comments and let me know your thoughts
on cloud gaming in general and we'll see
you next week